we bought this beautiful big sofa from Farmers recently
and it is legitimately my dream couch
it's called the Aspen and it's a modular sofa
so you can get different pieces and configure it however you like
and lately I've been on a bit of a mission to say the least
to overhaul this space
and today I'm adding some personality with some new cushions from Farmers
and right off the lounge is my dining room
and these shelves have just been crying out for attention
so when I was at Farmers
I picked up a few cute decor pieces to help tie it all together
this is the room that we painted green
if you caught that Reno so I've used that tone within the decor pieces
because it tones really nicely with the mid-century wood
I’m really happy with how the shelves came
but my favourite find was the marble chess set
because we're a big games family
so I can just see us sit around after dinner and playing
back in the lounge room
it's time for the finishing touches
and I can never resist a cute lamp for the ambiance
and I'm starting to think that maybe this room might finally be done
and if you've watched the progression of this room
you will know what a momentous occasion that is
it's feeling layered cosy and cohesive
and the cushions really helped with that
all of these items are Farmers brand M&Co
and I just know that they're quality to love for years to come